перемир'я на донбасі у край кришки
визнає доступні голову спеціальну
місії обсе Олександр хуг люди
продовжували хрону міжнародних суперечок
стрільців допускають на сюди послав вас
тельців фіналістів нам до сиду ж
складно по стежки ти на кордон україни то
російської федерації та кайна
контролюєте і вам особливо c100
suite pro гордону з movie у Луганську та
області
тоді нас систематично не допускають
новий механізм його роз'їзду не
конфлікту dns турелях навесні за вантажу з
бити його стиснути одні експерти на думку
енщик ситуації перед вириваєте на
заморожений конфлікт
німецький політолог штефан майстер паре
канони та масштабних наступальних
операцій на суд але в руку чика ти не в
роті
freemium газон я думаю ще буду я шукала
тебе на сході України
москва абсолютно в чому він isotek обл ана
пана розруха воїна тягни українсько
політично перебуваємо сама з огляду
москва ви чік і брік запис з алекс
експерти в астані в тому ще розрізані
насті в рядах сепаратисти в луганську то
донецька все менше
оточений США і контроль звуку Москви
автономних у групової ж не завершилася
та ціна
який росія платить за крим та за провину
дістати високу ціну краще вигнувши крим
чи в дружини maite йому жив 53 мод
з апаратів steel я надзвичайно she на
йому повернеться в желе рішення посади приводу
там уже вивести інтервал ці території
Аліна швидко і пить вищу частину і ну як
українці ви назвати ур інтеграцію
заплатить і захист чеку та виду росію
готовністю доз припини менше
агресивні політики щодо України
також передач про нас великих на de nous
типу скарбу tony ward поважають експерти
мінська 2 в дружини травня amis які членами
у води будуть складними і для виконання
самого початку попроси їх розпорядження
nebula допоміг поважаю за kidney аналітики
в асфальті вдалося і за планети акти в
не бій вигляді та